if you think like what is education like
you're basically downloading data and
algorithms into your brain
and it's it's actually amazingly
bad in conventional education because
like it shouldn't be like this huge
chore
to have a clarity of intention about
what you actually want to do
and why you want to do it is the most
important thing i think the people that
strive too much for the outer
scorecard sometimes find that it's a
little hollow when they get all through
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some lessons
from elon musk
oprah winfrey and other billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one understand the why with elon
musk
if you think you're like what is
education like you're basically
downloading data and algorithms into
your brain
and it's it's actually amazingly
bad in conventional education because
like it shouldn't be like this huge
chore
um so you're making it way way better um
but i mean i think i think i think a lot
of things that i would say you've
probably heard a hundred times um
and an effect are if not doing like the
more you can gamify
the uh the process of learning the
better
like for my kids i do not have to
encourage them to play video games yeah
okay
i have to like pry them from their hands
like like crack yes
yes like drop that crack needle yeah
yeah
you have that problem at your house too
yeah the crack isn't addictive
yeah so it's
you know it's it's it's to agree that
you can make uh somehow
learning like a game that then it's
better
and i think unfortunately like a lot of
education is very bored billion
um at you you've got uh you know
someone's standing up there kind of
lecturing at people
um and they've done the same lecture 20
years in a row and they're not very
excited about it
and that lack of enthusiasm you know
it's conveyed to the students
that they're not very excited about it
they don't know why they're there
like why are we learning this stuff we
don't even know why um in fact i think a
lot of things people learn probably
there's no point
in learning them um because they never
use them
in the future because who's going to
launch a rocket into space i mean that's
just like yeah yeah exactly that never
happens
um well you have to say like people i
think don't stand back and say well why
are we teaching people these things and
we should tell them
probably why we're teaching these things
because a lot of kids just
in school kind of puzzled as to why
they're there
yeah and i think if you can explain the
why of things
then that makes a huge difference to
people's motivation yeah then they
understand
they understand purpose yeah um
so i think that's pretty important
lesson number two live your life
with intention with oprah winfrey the
biggest transformation
for me was living my life with intention
you know what i know i live by
this law of that's the third law of
motion physics which you put out is
coming back
but before you even put it out you have
an intention and so to have
a clarity of intention about what you
actually want to do and why you want to
do it
is the most important thing and then to
just set that vision and have every
step you make move you in the direction
of that vision it doesn't mean that
every day it's going to happen
some days you're off track like i
intended to work out 45 minutes i only
got in
37 this morning well that's better than
two it's better than zero and that's
that's that's that's what i said okay
at least you got some movement in and
i'll go back and i'll make up the other
eight later
but i think you just made it up
actually as i was walking i think i
think this is gonna be eight minutes i'm
gonna make it up
so uh it's it's about it's daily renewal
it's not one big
gigantic goal it's every day coming back
giving yourself the opportunity to get
it right
because that's what every sunrise means
oh gosh it's another
chance to get it right it is yeah lesson
number three
focus on your inner scorecard with
warren buffett
i got an awful lot of good advice from
my dad and
and he didn't he didn't lay it on me i
mean he just you know
you you picked it up from him but there
was never any of this you know do this
do that
uh type of thing at all but but i think
he really
taught me that it's more important uh in
terms of what's on your inner score card
than your outer score card i mean some
people
get in a position where they they're
thinking all of the time of what
what the world's going to think of this
or that instead of what they themselves
think about and if
if your inner score card if you're if
you're comfortable with that
uh i think you're gonna you're gonna
have a pretty happy life and i think the
people that strive too much for the
outer score card uh
sometimes find it it's a little hollow
when they get all through lesson number
four
try a plant-based diet with grant
cardone
two weeks ago i went i went uh plant
only
plant-based plant-based i was afraid i
dropped the meat dude that's so
i want to do i did that for a week last
week yeah and i felt amazing
i had a lot more gas just from all the
plants i think but i was cleaning it out
that's really too much information for
me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like
and less inflammation and less pain yeah
i had noticed i have a little bit of
inflammation
in in my hands but yeah that hadn't
hadn't changed but
the plant-based thing i watched the game
the the game changing show
yeah and uh when he said
dude you're eating the middleman like
when i heard that that was enough for me
right eating the middleman
you're eating the middleman meaning the
cow the cow eats the grass
right you can go eat go right the source
is the grass yeah and as soon as i heard
that i'm like what the [ __ ] am i doing
eating the middleman
i ain't a middleman guy i want to go
directly to the source
where all the energy's at yeah i mean
like like
that was the line in the show that did
me wow and i had been thinking about it
too i've eaten meat for 60 years
i grew up on bacon four pieces of bacon
every day
so good uh oh yeah totally the eggs
i i have not eaten any meat
in 12 days
and my energy is freaking
this all day long oh wow
3 30 in the afternoon for the last 25
years i crashed at 3 30.
hard crash i mean like i'll see you guys
uh call me later okay what'd you do at 3
30. i got him i got a meeting yeah
that meeting was on that nap dude and
when i hit it i'm talking coma
[Laughter]
deep sleep better than sleep at night
sometimes it would be 30 minutes
sometimes it'd be an hour and a half
like comatose 12 days i'm i can't take a
nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
it's how good my energy do you think
you're going to stick with this do you
think you'll have meat sometimes
i mean i'm not i'm not like i'm not a
fanatic so yeah so
sometimes a little meat here and there
or something i'm just gonna eat what
makes me feel best
yeah so i don't care if it was meat if
it was
pork it was bacon but right now
um as long as i can find the greens
i haven't met i haven't missed the meat
wow
my digestion's better you know
my energy is freaking great yeah
i don't know man hey man how you doing
buddy good how are you
you got a book coming out don't you uh
you just came out
where can people get it get it on amazon
easiest spot
built to serve right there let's go man
if you guys don't know evan follow evan
carmichael he's got a new book out build
a serve go grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five think
through with bill gates i think success
is always a bit dangerous
uh you know and you can think
that whatever your success was was
because
you know you are magically uh gifted and
understanding things whereas of course
any success particularly a gigantic
success
is a huge number of factors including
hard work and understanding but
timing you know other people who came to
work with you other people who might
have done the same thing who somehow
messed up in doing it and so
often you'll you'll have too much
confidence about
what you understand uh you know in
science
uh as feynman said the easiest person to
fool is yourself
uh and so you have to force yourself to
go through
uh you know again and again and think
through is this the right thing to be
doing
you know will this work am i doing it
because it would be exciting if it
succeeded am i
really looking at these factors in fact
in polio several times we had to say to
ourselves
was it time to give up or really did we
think there was a prospect of
being able to move forward lesson number
six solve
problems with mark cuban one time you
know as you know i went to indiana and
in dallas in the mid 90s you know when
we had a good basketball team
we we literally would when we wanted to
listen to our big games like indiana
purdue go hoosiers
we would call somebody in bloomington
who would put a radio next to a speaker
phone
and dial us and we'd sit on the other
side listening over a speakerphone
drinking our beer and whipping it up or
doing whatever
and the internet was just starting to
happen and now i'm a tech geek and i'm
like into all of it
and we're like there's got to be a
better way to do this and so
one of my buddies from indiana todd
wagner was like look
we've been thinking about this and i'm
like no i'll figure it out i'm a
networking guy now
and so we looked for ways to
um stream indiana basketball we called
it net casting back then
over the brand new internet and so i
went out and bought a packard bell
90 megahertz computer and an isdn line
and downloaded all the software and i
said you know what i'm going to figure
it out
and lo and behold by oh
golly early 1995 we had figured out a
way
to we would we took
these eight-hour vcrs and connected it
to a local radio station record them
we'd bring them back go through this
process called encoding and put it up on
this
website we called audionet and then i'd
go to any online forum
aol prodigy compuserve uunet whatever it
was or you use use
usenet and i like if you're interested
in dallas sports at all because we
haven't gotten to indiana yet if you're
interested in dallas sports
go to this website audionet and back
then you had a dial up modem
you had to download this software called
tcpip
and you had to have software from your
internet provider
which meant that so few people knew how
to use it we had no idea if it would
work or not
but all of a sudden audionet went from
ten people a day to a hundred people
to a thousand people a day and as we
added radio stations they're getting
calls from all over the world from
people
who are listening to their shows on
demand not even lined
and then we worked with a company that
put together live software company
called zing
and we made it live and then everything
changed and that's really when streaming
was born
and we just grew that and then in 1998
we got into video changed the name to
broadcast.com
went public and it was the biggest ipo
in the history of the stock market at
the time
um and then we sold it to yahoo and
lesson number seven the last one before
a very special bonus clip is learn
your truth with jamie curran lima
wherever you're at in life right now at
this very moment
i believe everyone has a knowing inside
of them
i don't think it matters if they have a
faith or no faith i don't think about
any of that i think
everyone universally has a knowing or a
truth inside
uh and i think most people never learn
how to get still and hear it
and most people if they do get still and
hear it they're gonna know right now
live while they're listening to you and
me are they in the right
job they're supposed to be in or is
there
is are they are they playing it small
are they
in the right relationship or are they in
it
and dimming their own light because of
fear
that maybe they'll be alone we all have
a knowing right
and you know what i'll say about the
idea of um
giving up leveling up all of that i
think it's so important that
um you know in that moment where i had
the and again let me just say there's so
much i did wrong and i share all that
stuff too
one of the things i did right was when i
had this this
gut feeling as i'm sitting there with
this skin problem
this gut feeling oh you're supposed to
figure out how to how to create a beauty
company
even though i knew nobody in the beauty
industry had no connections had very
little money because television news
does not pay
very well um i had that knowing right
and yet i was sitting there in my dream
job and
when i look back at this journey of
three years of
constant rejection down to under a
thousand dollars in our bank account
literally getting knocked down over and
over from all of these
beauty retailers that i put on a
pedestal and i couldn't understand why
they were telling me i wasn't the right
fit for them
every time i would check in with my gut
right and maybe so many people out there
can relate to this because you
you feel like you're doing something
you're supposed to be doing but like for
me there was
no proof around me that my idea was
right there was
no traction in my business there was
nobody saying yeah that's a great idea
let me buy your product
and then i'm going to the beauty
retailers and they didn't believe
in the brand and everything around me
was saying you're wrong
and the easiest thing in life is to
confuse that with the truth
and i think the only way we know the
truth in life is when we get
good at getting still and hearing that
inner knowing
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place
and how you're going to actually take
action on it you jump to 91
chance of following through and when you
have public accountability and you
commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you on an individual level i think it is
always uh
it's always really good if if there's
something that you're incredibly
passionate about
and um and just sort of are fine to be
intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the one of
the the
the resolutions i came up with a number
of years ago
was to always value substance over
status
substance over prestige and
you know if i sort of it was giving my
younger self advice
on what to what to do or how to how to
think about um
your when's one's life i you know i
probably
i think i you know um i probably would
still go to stanford
um you know i might still go to law
school
but i'd ask i'd ask sort of i'd ask a
lot more questions
why why i was doing these things and i
think
i think if i was honest about it too
much of it was driven by
by prestige and status and not quite
enough about um really the substance of
uh
of trying to learn things and you know i
had sort of this i sort of
think of it as this sort of crazy
rolling quarter life crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm
where you know from the outside
everybody wanted to get in from the
inside everybody wanted to get out
um you know um after i lasted seven
months and three days and after uh
um and uh when i when i when i left one
of the people
down the hall said you know it's so
reassuring to see you leave peter i had
no idea it was possible to escape from
alcatraz
which which again uh and you know and
again i
and all you had to do was go through the
front door but our identity
um people's identities get so wrapped up
in
the things they compete for that it was
inconceivable for people
to actually do that and and then the
question was you know well how had i
ended up there
why had i not thought about that more
and i think it was
that i had taken too many of these
shortcuts of valuing
sort of what was prestigious what was
conventional over
what i uh what i really wanted to do so
i think i think always
substance over status
if you want even more insights into how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said
i was just going to be myself i find if
i don't get enough sleep then i'm
quite grumpy